I surrender yeah you guys this time we
have a 16 year old who is taking him
very soon right yeah she's super
stressed out about it
my son is taking a PSAT so far my son
just took it and PS it was really hard
and when in doubt you choose see right
you read a passage and then we have to
answer questions about it my emotions
are complicated not readily verifiable
like whose emotions are readily
verifiable I'm already zoning out and
what I do is both a challenge to my
egotism and it surrender to it deep it's
very teen angsty and a lot of needlessly
large words I don't even want to read it
that's why I'm skimming okay which
choice provides the best evidence for
the answer to the previous question oh
my gosh really go back and reread it it
was painful enough the first time I
don't know I don't want to think about
that questioning more moving on oh my
god that passage was obtuse Hughes an
SAT word 2 wrong 8 right I only have 4
correct it's very sad we can fill out
the form properly because I'm missing
one this is writing and language test
grammar nerd heaven people being
oppressed and including the LS bad we
dead so Sarah wants to add more words
and I want to delete the whole thing
took me a minute to understand actually
what they were asking I was asked unite
I don't understand as an adult I've
learned that if you use proper grammar
it makes you look really stupid
we both got 7 out of 9 we got the exact
same ones a couple of them were tricky
for wrong I'm never gonna live this down
I got three wrong so six right when you
get in that testing environment you
start to second-guess
maths has no calculator I'm sweating I'm
having anxiety just like looking at I
feel like I have to say math is
important kids but it's really which of
the following expressions is equal to
zero for some value of x I don't even
know what the question is asking me like
the names of like people I went to
kindergarten with I can recall no
problem but what expression is equal to
zero for some value of x what's the
point of the whatever happens it becomes
positive no matter what literally
nothing you just said oh my god I don't
want to subject my children to this 10
divided by zero would be 10 right no I
got it wrong because if I had gotten it
right the answer would be 1/2 but that's
not a choice do we have to divide the
whole thing like me my bread I can't
know 5 out of 6 - I got two legitimate
answers right and then I got two right
by guessing for a total of four I'm
trying to think of like a time after you
get through college when you really have
to sit and like be so focused for so
long it's horrible it's so hard I'm an
adult now math and I don't use this in
my life math I still don't like testing
period measure make me do that again